fred michel terrot bonjour bonjour
monsieur viol tombe dont joue aux
auditeurs président de la fédération des
républicains de martinique clap de fin
fred shero sur ce psychodrame qui agite
et votre formation politique il ya une
dizaine de jours ce sera définitivement
dans le sud sylvia 7 soutane en poste 1
et gabriel la grotte cours en suppliant
tout à fait donc nous avons fait une
réunion du comité territorial et en
soirée
après deux heures de discussions nous
avons remis les choses en l'état puisque
vous vous rappelez que le 17 décembre
dernier notre fédération avait donné une
investiture à monsieur la grand court
cette investiture de candidature tout à
fait il avait fait acte de candidature
après un processus de plusieurs semaines
le 7 janvier le jour de notre rentrée
politique il avait annoncé sa
candidature devant vous caméra
d'ailleurs s'était passé dans le journal
télévisé du 7 janvier dernier
et puis pendant le week-end changement
de programme
il a changé d'avis puis finalement il a
préféré passer son investiture à madame
à sa jolie ça fait pas jolie cette façon
de faire alors c'est vrai que ce n'était
pas tout à fait et les grandes dox
autres d'entre eux en fait il ya un
parallélisme des formes et c'est ce
qu'on a rappelé aux candidats
on ne peut pas en fait faire une passe
en retrait à une investiture on fait des
passes en retrait en foot ou au rugby
mais quand une une instance en
l'occurrence le comité départemental
délivre une investiture et que le
candidat change d'avis c'est son doigt
il doit remettre cette investiture à la
personne qui lui a donné c'est à dire le
comité territorial du 7 décembre
et c'est ce qui a été fait puisque hier
donc on a rappelé aux candidats il a
fallu ce comité de cession taurian ils
ont reconnu si vous voulez leurs erreurs
leurs précipitations allaient dans la
presse qu'il y avait un petit peu
changement et donc hier devant le comité
territorial ils ont reconnu leurs
erreurs leurs précipitations et donc à
une large majorité
l'investiture cette agitation à sylvia
c'est toute cette agitation a quand même
révélé certaines choses fred michel tir
au tout d'abord la première que
silverlight soutane et désormais le
poste 1 sur ce ticket dans le sud elle a
quand même pas sa crainte des
républicains est ce qu elle l'apprendra
est ce que vous l'avez décidé hier soir
en comité territorial
disons que si l'ue à cette soudaine
avaient été sollicités par un ensemble
des familles le fait qu'elle soit par
carte et ça ne pose pas à olemps pas de
problème puisque nous pouvons donner une
investiture un quelqu'un qui n'est pas
membre d'un autre parti politique
seulement il faut s'entourer de
précautions et c'est pour cette raison
que nous avons appris qu sûrement des as
il vient cette soudaine de venir au sein
du comité départemental expliquer ce
qu'elle souhaitait puisque au début elle
savait pas si elle voulait de soutien
simplement ou d'une investiture puisque
ces deux choses complètement différentes
alors on ira plus directement sont des
choses assez la fédération vous soutient
les militants vous soutiennent mais là
les restituer quelque chose d'officiel
jan ceulemans soutien de l'ensemble bay
un intérêt à y aller également ces deux
financements financier madrasa ya
soutien financier de la part de la
fédération et c'est ce qu'elle a
sollicité hier et donc la fédération lui
apporter s'en sortir dans ça se passera
lorsque l'iran préfecture lorsque votre
formation politique d'information pour
7,7 législatives vous mettrez sylvia cet
automne entre parenthèses les
républicains doivent obtenir les fonds
tout à fait sûr qu'elle a devancé ce qui
a été indiqué hier et c'est pour cette
raison qu'il fallait remettre les choses
dans l'ordre et s'assurer de la volonté
du candidat de bien être appuyé et
soutenu et avoir l'investiture et
coûteux c'est une candidate vous
recrutez vous obtiendrez les fonds
aujourd'hui ce qui est important c'est
de retenir que la fédération des
républicaines martinique donne
l'investiture à séduire site soutane
dans le sud et à madame rousseau dans le
centre et pour les autres ces
transcriptions bien le comité des parce
que vous avez lancé un appel à
candidature par exemple dans le nord
avec yan monplaisir il n'a pas répondu à
vos sollicitations la landriais timing
nous avons fait un appel à l'ensemble
des militants donc les militants vont se
positionner
nous avons déjà à délivrer 2 investiture
dans les prochaines semaines nous nous
sommes laissé hier
une deadline jusqu'à la fin du mois de
janvier de telle sorte que tous les
autres candidats se positionne
clairement sur les deux autres
circonscriptions et ce sera le cas dans
les semaines qui viennent et nous nous
pourrons délivrer les investitures dans
les autres circonscriptions et
signalement plaisir que l'on connaît ici
en martinique pour être une personnalité
assez marquée ne bouge pas puisqu'il se
tâte il réfléchit veut savoir comment
ils pourraient comment il pourrait être
utile pour le pays mais lui ne se
positionne pas qu'est ce que vous ferez
le viol temps nous donnerons
l'investiture à ceux qui se seront
positionnés les choses sont tout à fait
claires
nous sommes une fédération forte de plus
de mille militants vous avez des gens
qui travaillent depuis des années dans
cette fédération qui sont parfois dans
l'ombre qui peuvent maintenant exprimer
leur talent le compétences et leur
savoir faire en se présentant
ils se présenteront aux élections et
nous choisirons et le comité
départemental fera le choix entre les
différents candidats qui se présenteront
et andy priaulx plaisir s'ils décident
s'ils ne se prononce pas dit si cette
deadline com vous dites les candidats
savent maintenant qu'il ya une date
puisque ça a été décidé hier on l'a
rappelé nous n'allons pas attendre la
fin des élections pour se présenter mais
en sens contraire et semant info nous
nous nous présenterons donc d'ici la fin
du mois de janvier les choses seront
réglées
cette affaire sept soutane la grande
cour amène d'autres questions fred
michel tir haut c'est ce qui se dit
c'est ce qui a été rapporté fred michel
tir ou a fait le calcul ne pas y aller
face à son ami fred face à son ami jean
philippe ni lors que vous préparez le
coup d'après et que ce serait mieux pour
vous qui n'est pas quelqu'un qu'une trop
grande aura pour cette fois ci et que la
grand coup financerait le bon candidat
pour vous pour vos affaires personnelles
monsieur viol dont vous ne pouvez pas
vous pas vous pas vous journalistes de
cette qualité vous permettre de sisi je
l'entends et je redis je pose la
question on a entendu ici là oui mais je
te laisserais exactement comme ça rend
les choses un parti politique je le dis
très tôt au conseil municipal du
saint-esprit je les dis très tôt à la
famille du saint-esprit et il a été
d'ailleurs
le slogan de ma campagne et le nom de ma
liste le saint-esprit avant tout je dis
ce que je fais et je fais ce que je dis
si j'ai décidé de me consacrer au
saint-esprit en 2014 c'est jusqu'en 2020
au moins jusqu'en 2020
donc on ne va pas me faire changer la
vie d'autant vous ne vous a pas échappé
qu'il y à un non cumul des mandats
notamment deux mandats de député et de
maire je ne cours pas après le mandat je
fais partie de ceux qui pensent qu'il
faut se consacrer à une mission et qui
trop embrasse mal étreint
et ne comptez pas sur moi pour faire la
chasse aux mandats je me consacre au
saint-esprit
je reste dans ma mission maintenant j'ai
fait un appel à tous les militants de la
fédération
le comité territorial ne force pas un
membre à se présenter les membres sont
libres de se présenter ou de ne pas se
présenter
nous avons reçu plusieurs candidatures
dans les différentes circonscriptions
le comité tranche en fonction des
candidatures qui ont été reçus nous
avons déjà délivré deux investiture et
d'ici là moi la fin du mois de janvier
nous délivrerons deux autres investiture
fred michel terrot comment voyez vous
cette bataille électorale dans le sud
entre jean-philippe ni lors que vous
connaissez bien et s'il ya sa soutane y
voient déjà une première bataille c'est
la bataille des présidentielles avant la
bataille dit des législatives de la
bataille des présidentielles est
important aussi parce qu'elle va
permettre aussi de donner au président
de la république et au président de la
république n'est pas fort s'il n'a pas
derrière lui une majorité ce qui est
important de voir c'est que les membres
de notre famille politique et notamment
des républicains ils vont appartenir un
grand groupe et ce qu'il faut rappeler
aux martiniquais que ça ne la sert en
rien d'envoyer des députés à l'assemblée
nationale qui ne font pas partie de
grands groupes savent et à l'assemblée
nationale en fonctionne par groupe
si vous n'avez pas un groupe de 200 ou
300 députés derrière vous aimez ça ne
sert à rien c'est ce que la vérité isolé
c'est ce que vous direz aux côtés de ses
classiques soutane sur de travail vous
souhaite vous êtes un député isolé
aujourd'hui nous avons des députés à
l'assemblée nationale
son trait c'est très sympathique mais
ils ne sont pas efficaces parce qu'ils
appartiennent à deux du petit groupe et
vous le dit à jean thriller lorsque vous
le croisez vous l'avez croisé le temps
il appartient à des petits groupes
quand vous êtes dans un groupe de quinze
vous ne pouvez pas pesé dans une
assemblée nationale qui comporte 577
députés aujourd'hui et depuis des
décennies ces deux grands groupes qui
règne à l'assemblée nationale le groupe
socialiste où le groupe républicain
quand la droite est au pouvoir c'est le
groupe républicain fort de 300 membres
qui votent les lois quand vous
n'appartient peuvent appartenait par un
de ces deux grands groupes
eh bien vous est cantonné à poser des
questions et à vous asseoir au bout de
trois minutes
moi je ne veux pas que les députés de la
martinique se cantonne un tel rôle c'est
pour ça que j'ai vite les martiniquais à
faire le choix des candidats qui
appartiennent à des grands groupes et
sylvia cette soudaine karine rousseau et
les autres candidats que je ne
désignerai il a donné une date de
l'arrêt feriel du mois et bien seront
appartiendront à des grands groupes
si les électeurs l'auf en confiance
distendu j'invite les électeurs à faire
ça à faire confiance à ceux qui s'ils
vont dans des grands coups en
distinguant miguel laventure mais va se
prononcer quand miguel laventure a déjà
fait acte de candidature
notre famille politique dira si oui ou
non nous les républiques et nous
soutenons nous donnons l'investiture à
monsieur miguel laventure merci d'avoir
été avec nous ce matin fred michel turon
rappelle que vous êtes président de la
fédération martinique des républicaines
martinique bonne lumière ci avoue bonne
journée à tous